le 7 8 de ce 23 octobre se poursuit on
va parler d'un droit peut-être méconnu
celui qui concerne les chiens guides
d'aveugles une pétition circulant ce
moment pour conforter ses droits et pour
en parler Bernadette pillois et sur ce
plateau bonsoir à vous vous êtes
malvoyants de guyancourtoise secrétaire
de l'Association nationale des maîtres
de chien guide d'aveugle on va d'abord
faire un rappel de la loi depuis 2005
les chiens guides d'aveugles peuvent
circuler librement partout avec vous
dans les lieux publics comme dans les
centres commerciaux les transports et
les taxis c'est une réalité mais c'est
pas toujours très simple à appliquer non
ça se passe au quotidien véritablement
pour les personnes au quotidien la
plupart du temps ça se passe très bien
mais hélas cette loi n'est pas assez
connue
et donc régulièrement nous sommes
refusés par les agents de sécurité qui
ont une consigne pas de chien les taxis
qui pensent qu'ils ont droit de nous
refuser ce qui fait que c'est un petit
peu dur pour nous de toujours devoir
expliquer la loi de devoir expliquer que
nos chiens sont bien éduqués que nos
chiens guides ce sont nos yeux et que
donc on peut pas laisser nos yeux à la
porte qu'ils ont le droit aussi de ne
pas avoir de muselière c'est difficile
justement de se faire entendre et de se
faire comprendre
ça semble assez logique finalement oui
on nous dites mais ce n'est pas
forcément admis partout tout le monde ce
n'est pas demi par tout le monde parce
que ce sont des chiens on est tout à
fait d'accord ils ont quatre pattes une
que la mienne remue sa queue tout le
temps parce qu'elle est toujours joyeuse
ton plateau justement avec mon sur les
images elle est très sage parce que les
chiens guides sont des chiens éduqués
donc en trois mots les chiens guides
jusqu'à trois mois restent avec leur
mère chien ensuite vont dans des
familles d'accueil qui leur apprennent
le Beaba de la bonne éducation d'un
chien c'est à dire ne pas tirer ne pas
monter sur les fauteuils ne pas voler
marcher en laisse sans tirer ensuite
vers un an il rentre dans une école où
ils sont éduqués alors là on est très
très strict on dit jamais qu'on dresse
les chiens guides on les éduque c'est
très important pour nous
et ils sont éduqués par des éducateurs
professionnels des professionnels de
grands talents et ensuite ils sont remis
donc entre 18 mois et deux ans à des
personnes aveugles ou malvoyantes donc
ils nous sont remis gratuitement grâce à
cette chaîne de solidarité ce ne sont
pas les impôts des gens c'est le les
dons la solidarité et le partage qui
font qu'ensuite avec nos chiens nous
retrouvons une liberté de mouvement une
liberté de circulation qui vaut vraiment
le coup du coup de faire un petit effort
pour nous laisser aller partout et comme
il y a une loi justement si jamais on
vous refuse l'accès avec vos chiens
guide il est possible de déposer des
plantes j'imagine que l'association la
nationale des maîtres de chiens guides
d'aveugles
que ça c'est dire que la loi était bien
faite vous rendez compte en plus des
gens contents de la loi existante c'est
quand même assez rare je le souligne là
je viens je ne demande pas d'argent je
demande rien du tout sauf l'application
de la loi c'est-à-dire que la loi nous
dit que
le refus de chien guide sanctionné d'une
amende de 150 à 450 euros dites de 3e
catégorie c'est-à-dire que on est
vraiment refusé à un endroit il y a rien
à faire on ne peut pas négocier nous
sommes en droit d'appeler la police qui
dressera immédiatement nous mettre de
chien guide la police viendra et
dressera immédiatement une contravention
de 150 euros c'est à dire qu'on n'est
pas obligé de porter plainte alors on
aide nos adhérents parce que on est là
pour ça d'ailleurs ceux qui sont pas
adhérents d'être tous les maîtres de
chiens guide et je m'en occupe donc de
ces refuges sur le plan national mais
chaque maître de chien guide peut faire
appel à la police chaque année vous
traitez combien de dossiers justement
sur ces revenus écrire téléphoner
signaler une bonne centaine mais en
revanche chaque maître de chien guide
essuie
ça dépend si on sort beaucoup ou pas ça
dépend où on va mais plusieurs
tentatives de refus par mois alors nous
ne s'enseigner la loi ça c'est une
évident cette loi qui existe depuis 2005
et qui vous permet d'accéder dans les
différents lieux pour autant pour les
gens qui ne savent pas ou qui ne savent
pas en tout cas comment faire vous
faites des formations également vous les
assurez auprès des taxis par exemple
exactement la prochaine fois c'est le 22
novembre à Paris on a choisi de prendre
la la enfin le problème à la base et
donc puisqu'on est surtout refusé par
des taxis on participe à la formation
des chauffeurs de taxi et au bout des
heures de formation c'est vrai que les
futurs chauffeurs nous disent ah mais
maintenant on a compris ce que c'est
qu'un chien guide ce que c'est pour nous
pour vous aussi
parce que nos chiens ne montent pas sur
les banquettes j'ai toujours dans mon
sac quand il pleut une serviette pour
essuyer les pattes de mon chien etc
alors notre prochain objectif c'est la
formation des agents de sécurité parce
que donc l'autre grand sujet grand
problème ce sont les agents de sécurité
à qui on a dit pas de chien et à qui on
a oublié de dire pas de chien sauf les
chiens guides d'ailleurs pour e-commerce
nous distribuions gratuitement des
vitrophanies à coller c'est à dire une
c'est quand même assez joli par utile
interdit aux animaux sauf au chien guide
d'aveugle effectivement petit
autocollant que j'ai là bien le voir à
l'écran orange et bleu si vous voyez ça
voilà accepter les personnes malvoyantes
aveugle ou avec leur chien guide on va
juste marquer une petite pause parler de
la pétition aussi et parler des chiens
qui sont en formation parce que vous
demandez que la loi soit étendue à ces
chiens qui sont en formation on va juste
faire une pause on va écouter le
témoignage de Miro c'est un artiste
comédien aveugle il joue sur scène avec
son chien guide fa dièse Johanna soudri
les a rencontrés tous les deux c'était
lors du festival or fait auquel il
participait le spectacle était joué à la
Royal Factory à Versailles il y a
quelques temps
le problème
c'est que mon chien il a une carte
d'identité parce que le chien guide vous
savez il peut aller partout il va dans
l'avion en cabine s'il vous plaît aller
à l'hôtel il peut aller dans le taxi
il peut aussi passer les frontières et
pour passer les frontières donc il a
besoin d'une carte d'identité
et sa carte d'identité au toucher elle
est exactement comme ma carte
d'invalidité elle a le même format
avec la photo en bas à gauche avec les
deux petits points sont
et comédien et aveugle atteint d'une
rétinite pigmentaire il a
progressivement perdu la vue auparavant
kinésithérapeute Miro décide de se
lancer dans le théâtre et décrire un one
man show avec mon premier chien il m'est
arrivé des choses pas possible et moi je
racontais ça pour pour me
vider un peu mon sac quoi et en fait les
gens c'est mort de rire après on dirait
tu devrais toujours écrire un spectacle
c'est drôle ça permet d'avoir une
meilleure compréhension de handicap en
dédramatisant voilà j'explique en fait
comment ça se passe avec un chien et
puis après comment ça se passe avec une
canne et après ça commence à se passe
quand on est malvoyant mais tout ça en
fait c'est pédagogique instructif je
veux apprendre le but c'est on rit pas
pour rire mais on rit pour apprendre
je fouille dans mon sac
je crois reconnaître ma carte
d'invalidité je la prends et je la donne
à la dame
qu'est-ce que vous m'auriez dit vous
vous êtes trompé vous m'avez donné la
carte de votre chien et elle
mais c'est pour vous sur la
et moi j'étais persuadé que c'était moi
si vous voulez c'est une vieille carte
vous voyez j'ai pas fait trop faire
depuis 20 ans je me suis dit elle m'a
pas encore connu
je lui dis c'est moi
mais j'étais plus jeune
puis je revenais de vacances sur cette
Mureaux partage donc la vue d'être avec
son chien guide fa dièse qui surnomme
Fafa un acteur à part entière lui ça
fait 6 mois
la première fois on a déjà fait un
ensemble et il a eu il a eu comme on dit
le
tracait pas tu dis doucement ils vont
pas te manger
une qualité à ajouter sur son CV de
chiens guide
Fafa et Miro sur scène Bernadette
pillois et son chien peut-être sur scène
aussi oui elle est très comédienne donc
elle s'appelle Dakota et c'est un flat
coat retriever de 4 ans de l'école de
chien guide de Paris et donc comme ça
justement ça ça permet de sensibiliser
aussi au problème des différemment vous
entendez vous tous
j'ai trouvé ça drôle c'est vrai que tous
les moyens sont bons pour faire
connaître et reconnaître par tout le
monde que la personne handicapée est
avant tout une personne et c'est pour ça
que j'en arrive directement à ma chère
pétition dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure nous avons décidé donc mon
association l'Association nationale des
maîtres de chiens guides d'aveugle qui
est une association entièrement gérée
par des personnes aveugles ou
malvoyantes et on a tous conseillé
d'administration des chiens guides donc
on a d'abord fait une grande marche le
12 mai partout avec mon chien guide pour
se faire connaître et on s'est aperçu
que ça suffisait pas encore
et donc on a décidé de lancer leur
pétition pas vraiment c'est un texte de
soutien euh pour deux aspects donc cette
loi soit mieux connue et que le statut
du du chien guide soit vraiment reconnu
comme quelque chose de spécifique alors
c'est un animal mais c'est pas une chose
ce sont nos yeux ce sont nos compagnons
donc cette ce texte de soutien a signé
je crois que vous avez donné la bonne
manière pour pour soutenir ce texte donc
nous voulons que le texte soit mieux
connu et d'autre part nous voudrions que
les les droits qui qui nous sont
reconnus d'aller partout avec nos chiens
guides soit étendu aussi au chien en
formation parce que pour le moment ce
n'est pas le cas c'est à la bonne
volonté des uns et des autres or plus
nos chiens en éducation iront tôt
partout dans les transports en commun et
autres mieux l'éducation se passera et
plus rapidement et cette pétition qui a
été lancée très récemment a déjà
recueilli plus de 26000 27000 signatures
mais après ce que 27000 signatures c'est
à dire 20 000 sur notre site
je remercie d'ailleurs les ceux qui nous
ont proposé gratuitement cette cette
plateforme de soutien qui s'occupait
essentiellement de cause humanitaires et
qui nous ont beaucoup aidés et on a fait
aussi signal signer par papier et j'ai
appelé tout à l'heure le siège et on
était à plus de 6500 signatures papier
je vais redonner deux sites Internet qui
se sont affichés je vais également les
données www partout avec mon chien guide
tout attaché point WordPress.com et puis
également pour les chiens guitare
d'aveugle
www.am.cga.fr voilà pour avoir tous les
renseignements qui sont nécessaires et
toutes les informations dont nous
parlons ce soir une dernière question
vous êtes en contact aussi avec la
ministre délégué chargée des personnes
handicapées marie-arlett Carlotti un
rendez-vous est prévu alors un
rendez-vous est quasiment prévu ça y est
vu le succès de notre texte de soutien
on avait du mal à avoir des contacts et
comme par hasard ça y est on a plus de
contacts on pense la fin novembre début
décembre et déjà deux parlementaires ont
posé des questions l'un au Sénat l'autre
va reposer un à l'Assemblée nationale
pour dire que vraiment il faut faire
quelque chose pour nous et
signer cette pétition c'est ce sera un
geste de solidarité pas très compliqué
pour chacun de vous et ça vous aidera à
changer votre regard à tous sur nous
personne handicapées merci Bernadette
Pilou et merci à Dakota aussi vous êtes
venu toutes les deux sur ce plateau
association nationale des maîtres de
chiens guides d'aveugles et si vous
voulez plus d'informations les sites
internet bien sûr qui se sont affichés
et que je citais tout à l'heure on va
parler aménagement de la région
Île-de-France durant la suite du 7 8 on
va parler aussi développement durable
dans un instant pendant la chronique
environnement qui va débuter tout de
suite
développement durable juste après ce
reportage le siècle gère le réseau
d'assainissement de la couvrance et
englobe notamment les communes de
Maurepas et de Coignières des travaux de
rénovation sont en cours pour remplacer
les plus anciennes canalisations
certaines ont une cinquantaine d'années
des canalisations d'eau de 40 ans d'âge
usés et fissurés des branchements
d'origine parfois effectuées à la
va-vite et des fuites et des inondations
chez les particuliers en cas de forte
pluie le syndicat intercommunal
d'assainissement de la couvrance
intervient actuellement sur les communes
de Coignières et de Maurepas afin de
mettre le réseau aux normes et rajeunir
les canalisations nous intervenons chez
les particuliers qui ont des problèmes
de conformité de raccordement
c'est-à-dire dont les eaux usées se
déversent dans le réseau d'eau pluviales
ou inversement les eaux pluviales ce qui
est moins grave mais qui est quand même
un peu gênant dans les eaux pluviales
des toits se déversent dans le réseau
d'eau usées la législation française et
notamment la loi sur l'eau de 2006
impose désormais aux particuliers aux
entreprises la mise aux normes du réseau
les concernant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons maintenant les armes
juridiques pour obliger les gens à se
mettre conformité les gens les
particuliers les entreprises et puis
d'autre part nous bénéficions d'aide de
subventions dès lors qu'il y a un
programme groupé l'Agence de l'eau c'est
Normandie et le Conseil général des
Yvelines prennent alors charge 75
sous d'investissement 144 particuliers
sont concernés par ces travaux sur les
deux communes à partir de 2013 le SIAC
procédera aux réparations du réseau chez
77 entreprises